all right last one story that popped up
last week good time to get attention
uh because it was kind of toward the end
of the slow time this offseason melvin
gordon the chargers running back wanting
his new contract willing to hold out
willing to demand a trade willing to sit
out into the regular season we'll see
about all of that we'll see what happens
if and when the chargers don't give
gordon what he wants bottom line is he's
in the final year of a rookie contract
he's due to make 5.605 million this year
he wants to get paid more than that and
the reality is running backs the supply
outweighs the demand and only the truly
special running backs get paid huge
money melvin gordon does not fall into
that category of truly special so i i
think and i'm a big this is tough for me
i'm a big believer
and players taking a stand and players
disrupting the system and players saying
give me what i deserve the problem is if
you overplay your hand when you take
that stand it blows up in your face so
it could be that melvin gordon like
remember when maurice jones drew sat out
all of the offseason all of not all the
offseason but all the training camp in
the preseason and then caved that could
be what happens with melvin gordon if
you over overplay it and then you have
to cave where are you
if the team doesn't wave the fines that
you incur during
pre-season during training camp you end
up out a lot of money and you have
nothing to show for it you have to
continue to wait for your shot at the
open market so that's the downside for
melvin gordon because he's not one of
the truly special running backs in the
nfl if he does hold out there may end up
being no easy way out of this for him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports